due in part to our sanctions and Export
controls Russia has become increasingly
isolated on the world stage and they've
been forced to look to like-minded
States for military equipment as we've
been warning publicly one of those
States is North Korea our information
indicates that the Democratic peoples
Republic of Korea recently provided
Russia with ballistic missile launchers
and several ballistic missiles on this
30th of December 2023 Russian forces
launched at least one of these North
Korean ballistic missiles into Ukraine
this missile appears to have landed in
an open field in the zapara region and
on January 2nd Russia launched multiple
North Korean ballistic missiles into
Ukraine including as part of its
overnight aerial attack we expect Russia
and North Korea to learn from these
launches and we anticipate that Russia
will use additional North Korean
missiles to Target Ukraine's civilian
infrastructure and to kill innocent
Ukrainian
civilians these North Korean ballistic
missiles are capable of ranges of
approximately 900 km that's about 550
mil this is a significant and concerning
escalation in the dprk support for
Russia now in return for its support we
assess that Pyongyang is seeking
military assistance from Russia
including fighter aircraft surfac to air
missiles armored vehicles ballistic
missile production equipment or
materials and other Advanced
Technologies this would have concerning
security implications for the north I'm
sorry for the Korean Peninsula and the
indopacific
region we've also said publicly that
Russia is seeking to acquire close-
range ballistic missiles from Iran at
this time we do not believe that Iran
has delivered close-range ballistic
missiles to Russia however the United
States is concerned that Russian
negotiations to acquire close-range
ballistic missiles from Iran are
actively
advancing